hi everyone thanks so much for joining
me today so today we are going to have
long day I'll just show the schedule
once again so that you guys are aware of
all the breaks and you know the schedule
for the day the agenda for today uh so
but the broad topic that we'll be
discussing today is about how to
interpret or explain machine learning
models right
so the schedule for today is the
following so we are going to break it
down into like four parts or four
sessions uh from 9 to 10 20 am we are
going to do a brief intro discuss a
little bit about why do we even need to
care about interpretability or should we
care about it or are there scenarios
where we need to care about it and
others where we do not need to care
about it and then I'll give a quick
overview of inherently interpretable
models and don't worry if you're not
completely sure what that means we'll
get to that from 10 20 to 10 40 we'll do
a 20 minute break from 10 40 to 12 we'll
have the second part which is which
we'll be focusing on post hoc
explanation methods uh from 12 to 1
we'll have lunch we'll give a five
minutes of settle in time from one to
one five so from one five to 125 we'll
do some breakout groups where you get to
sort of discuss with you know other
folks hear about some questions before
we get into the second half and from 125
to 245 we'll do the third session on
evaluating and empirically and
theoretically analyzing model
interpretations and explanations so then
we do a 15 minute break from 245 to 3
and then from 3 to 4 we basically
continue the discussion on our empirical
and theoretical analysis and conclude
with some future research directions
okay so this is the agenda so feel free
to kind of pick and choose the things
that would be most useful for you and so
on but this is a high level overview
does that sound good okay awesome
all right so with that let's get into
the initial bits of today's talk so
since we have uh the whole day today we
are going to ease in by talking a little
bit about you know what exactly are we
thinking about when we try to interpret
machine learning models where can this
be useful when can it not be useful and
so on right uh so I'm sure several of
you are familiar with scenarios like
these for example you know Healthcare or
criminal justice system or finance and
so on and also several other
applications like whether it is you know
social networks like Facebook or Twitter
whether it's your online product
shopping portals like Amazon or
Goodreads and many many more uh so why
am i showing all these applications is
because today machine learning is in all
these applications and of course I don't
need to tell you guys that because you
know Stanford being the Hub of machine
learning I'm sure you guys have
encountered applications read about
research you know know being in touch
with like companies which build apps for
any of these applications right so
they're all using machine learning so
given that that's the reality of today's
world now we want to ask given the topic
of this Workshop we want to ask is model
understanding needed in every such
application what do you guys think so
there are several such applications do
we want to understand what machine
learning models are doing in each of
these settings or Are there specific
settings where there might be more
helpful in order to sort of understand
model predictions or Model Behavior
any thoughts
okay yeah I think it will be more
critical to understand
ings are like um Criminal Justice System
then it's just recommendations
right great and why do you say that
um
I think it's not the effect of the
machine Learning System on the
individuals or like the system safety
level is like more high stakes yeah
them yeah right that's exactly right
right so we may not want to understand
or at least you know the emphasis or
importance of understanding how machine
learning models are behaving is probably
much higher in settings like healthcare
or criminal justice or like you know
loan approval decisions and these kinds
of settings because the decisions that
we are making there are probably going
to impact people's life right their
health and you know their livelihood and
so on whereas if Facebook for example
recommends a wrong friend to you you
would you know it's fine like you would
probably not be very pleased but that's
right at the end of the world you'll
probably click a button there and move
on right so that's exactly right right
so first I want to kind of start this
discussion by saying because this is a
very hot topic of debate whenever I give
talks and you know do these discussions
it's like you know there are always
audiences that come up and say oh but
like we don't need interpretability here
right so I want to kind of start with
that upfront that not all applications
require
understanding of models and their
predictions right so for example as you
rightly pointed out you know things like
ad or product or friend recommendations
and so on and also settings where there
is no human intervention involved so
there is no human who is looking at a
prediction and trying to make a final
decision so where there's no human
intervention involved in the final
decision making in such applications you
may not really even need to think about
model understanding right and why is
that the case exactly because there are
very few consequences to making
incorrect predictions in these cases of
course you know if you make a lot of
incorrect predictions then a company
might lose revenue and so on but as long
as you know the number of incorrect
predictions you're making are few the
consequences for those are like much
lesser right and a lot of these problems
especially when we think about
recommender systems like ad or or you
know movies or products and so on these
problems are extremely well studied and
a lot of systems or machine learning
models that are built for these settings
have already been extensively validated
uh in real world applications which
means we can pretty much trust that
these models are going to make you know
accurate predictions quoted right but
you know again as machine learn the
reason why xai and in fact this whole
research on a trustworthy machine
learning or emphasis on safety has
become popular in the last you know few
years is because of the increasing
deployment of machine learning models in
settings like healthcare or Justice or
you know financing and so on right and
the nature of the decisions in these
kinds of settings is that the decisions
are often high stakes and as you rightly
pointed out they impact human lives
their health their finances and the more
important thing is a lot of these
settings are relatively less well
studied it and models that people are
developing for these settings have not
been extensively validated on these
settings right so the combination of
those two things is what is pushing
people to consider uh interpretability
or explainability or model understanding
seriously
so what what what is the result of this
kind of a setting so we talked about the
settings being high stakes and we talked
about the settings are relatively
understudied so what does that imply
right that implies that accuracy
Computing accuracy of a model is no
longer enough the reason is a lot of
times since these settings are not very
well studied the train test data which
you are using to build your model and
test your model may not even be
representative of the data that will be
encountered once you deploy the model
right so if that is the case then
accuracy numbers kind of become a bit
meaningless right and apart from this in
these kinds of settings a lot of
auxiliary criteria are also critical so
for example you need the models to be
fair and not discriminate against you
know minority groups there is also
legislation or loss or rules that are
coming out which are actually trying to
mandate right to explanation when models
are being used to make critical
decisions and of course there are safety
uh you know criteria that also need to
be accounted for when we develop these
kinds of models right so accuracy alone
is not enough anymore in these kinds of
settings emphasis on other kind of
criteria is also becoming very important
and the the sort of both the interesting
and the challenging thing is that these
auxiliary criteria are often hard to
quantify right so for example I might be
able to say that oh I want my model to
be fair right but can I quantify it
perfectly completely maybe not right and
the definition differs from setting to
setting similarly we want our models to
fail safely what does that mean we are
not always sure what that means so in
some sense there is uh you know some the
challenges associated with like
completely quantifying these auxiliary
criteria is also what puts the spotlight
back on understanding machine learning
models right so in some sense this this
uh the challenge of being hard to
quantify is basically what comes out as
incompleteness in problem formulation
which makes it harder to sort of
quantify something and optimize for it
right away which is what typically as
machine learning researchers if there is
a measurable quantity we can always do
you know optimize for it right so we can
always do something with it optimize for
it but in this case we are not
completely sure how to even specify it
so there is incompleteness in this kind
of problem formalization in these
settings
so our solution to all this is how about
we try to understand the Model Behavior
in different ways shapes and forms and
once we see it we are probably going to
know if there is a problem with it
either with safety or with fairness or
any of the criteria that we care about
right so just to summarize our
discussion when and why do we need model
understanding so model understanding
becomes critical when one models are not
extensively validated in real world
applications and train and test data
that we have are potentially not
representative of real-time data and the
second reason why model understanding
becomes critical is some of the key
criteria that are required in your
setting are hard to quantify and we need
some kind of a you will know it when you
see it approach to figure out if there
are any problems or things that violate
those criteria
right
um circuit okay are there any questions
so far
uh could there be another setting where
you might care about explainability such
as like
um like you want to understand some data
Maybe first like science or something
like that so you're training machine
learning model and then you look at that
an explanation to just gain
understanding is that like you see that
as fitting in here as well or is that a
separate topic yeah no that's a good
question so you're saying explanations
as a way for augmenting our own
knowledge right so that's definitely I
think a lot of this biomedical Sciences
uses uh explainability for that quite a
bit uh so I would I think it is kind of
probably not touched upon here but I
would say two things about that it's
definitely an approach that is being
followed and I think it is perfectly
useful uh at the same time I think we
might also want to be a bit careful
about sort of your model is learning
this from the data so you are taking all
of that and trying to form human
knowledge out of it so what if there are
some spurious things that are being
picked up right so the reason why I'm
not going into that track is I think it
has a lot more once you open that
Pandora's Box there is a lot more that
would come out but definitely I mean
it's being used that way these days uh
to sort of because you know models are
kind of learning things that people may
not know and explanations are a way to
transfer that knowledge but how much of
that knowledge should be transferred how
to figure out if what part of that
knowledge is furious what part of that
is valuable I think there are some like
gray areas there which need to be
thought through more which unfortunately
I'm not sure if it's happening enough
sure okay
all right okay so I'm going to keep
going so now that we have talked so much
about when and why model understanding
might be useful I'm just going to show a
few applications just to concretize all
of this right and we'll use some nice
simple fun pictures to see the different
use cases in which explanations might be
helpful or model interpretations might
be helpful you'll not only see the
application but you'll also see examples
of what an explanation or interpretation
could look like right so let's say that
now we have a predictive model
uh so which takes his input some images
and then it makes predictions about the
animal that's in the images right and
this model was built by a developer so
you pass this image and then it's
rightly predicting that this image is
Siberian Husky but if you sort of probe
the model a little bit more and see what
are the areas of the image that the
model is focusing on what you see is
that the model is focusing on the snow
pieces right so in some sense while the
prediction looks okay once you see the
features that the model is looking at or
paying attention to you see that it's
actually not looking at the animal but
rather at the background or trying to
find snow in the image right and that's
what it is using to predict the image as
Siberian Husky so in some sense this
understanding is basically what tells
the developers that you know model is
relying on spurious or incorrect
features and you know maybe we need to
debug this model better improve it and
so on right so here is a clear use case
where model understanding is helping
with debugging of models which I am sure
several offers with the researchers
engineer scientists who use machine
learning models can find this incredibly
valuable okay so now let's look at
another use case so where uh there's a
predictive model that is being used by a
particular judicial facility to make
decisions about if people should be
released on bail or not right again I
just want to put a disclaimer out there
that I'm not advocating for any such
applications but unfortunately there
already exists some of these out there
so you know the the way we are thinking
about it is we are basically trying to
analyze that setting a bit more okay all
right so these kinds of models they take
the details of the defendant like for
example the defendants
socioeconomic status the demographic
attributes their past criminal history
and so on and predict if the person
should be released or not or is the
person to too risky to be released or
not right so in this case the model is
taking the details of this defendant and
making a prediction but then this does
not give any information to the judge
about whether or when and how to use
that prediction whether they can rely on
this prediction or not okay but if we
show the judge some of the key features
that the model is focusing on for
example maybe the model is looking at
race and gender when making this
prediction the judge will realize that
this prediction is basically biased it's
being based on features like race and
gender which should not happen so the
judge is going to hopefully discount
such a prediction and make his own
decision right so in this case model
understanding has helped facilitate bias
detection
similarly in another scenario now we can
think about end users so Banks often
have such models which they imply in
order to sort of predict who should be
given a loan right so loan applicants
details or their application will be
passed on to the bank Bank the bank then
runs the predictive model and determines
if a person should get a loan or not now
let's say an applicant is denied a loan
if we just tell that person your loan is
denied sorry that's it that's not very
helpful because now the person doesn't
know what to do anymore right so they
don't have a means for further action
but instead if we actually tell them
increase your salary by say 5 or 10K or
50k pay your credit card bills on time
uh for say about three months then you
know come back and reapply and you'll
get a loan that is actionable
information that the person can use in
order to sort of work on their profile
come back and reapply right so in fact
these kinds of mandations uh have been
encoded in some of the legislations like
gdpr especially for the finance sector
or Banks which are using predictive
models in deciding on loan applications
and other such things uh so in this case
model understanding is helping provide
recourse to individuals who are
adversely affected by model predictions
right and similarly if we think of a
healthcare scenario uh so if there's a
doctor that is relying on model
predictions and the model is basically
taking a bunch of data and labeling
patients as like healthy or sick now the
doctor again if they just look at the
predictions they have no way of knowing
which ones to rely on which ones they
should apply their own judgment to and
so on but if we had like a full
understanding of what the underlying
model is potentially doing so for
example in this case if that's what the
model is exactly doing and the doctor
sees that the doctor can quickly realize
that you know the model is using
irrelevant features like ID numbers when
making predictions on females of
population right and therefore they
should not trust the model's predictions
at least for that subgroup
so in this case model understanding is
helping assess if and when to trust
model predictions when making decisions
right so such an understanding can in
fact also be helpful for regulatory
authorities in deciding if a model
should be sort of approved for broader
deployment or not right so in this case
if an authority like FDA looks at that
explanation of what the model is doing
the authority might realize that okay
this model is just using irrelevant
features on half the population which is
basically all the females right and so
it's not really for deployment at this
point so in this sense model
understanding can also allow us to wet
models to determine if they're suitable
for real world deployment okay so just
to summarize there is obviously a lot of
utility to sort of understanding models
and their predictions for example you
know applications like debugging bias
detection recourse you know if and when
to trust model predictions wetting
models to assist for suitability for
deployment all of these are like use
cases or applications that are enabled
by model understanding and there are
several stakeholders that benefit from
this right so including end users like
ourselves who might apply for loans at
Banks or decision makers like judges
doctors policy makers or regulatory
agencies or researchers scientists
engineers all of us can benefit from
this in some way or the other
okay
right
any quick thoughts questions or we can
move on
great okay so now that we have discussed
so much about where model understanding
can be beneficial when it may not be
beneficial and so on let's take a step
back and think about how can we actually
achieve model understanding right so
while there are you know several
approaches to do this at a very high
level very broadly you can think of two
classes of strategies that are used to
achieve model understanding so one is
build models that are inherently
interpretable right so for example
models like you know linear regressions
logistic regressions or shallow decision
trees or like small rule-based models so
these are all models that are often
considered as inherently interpretable
because you know you can look at those
set of rules and as a human we can
understand what the model is doing when
making its predictions right of course
one could argue that you know if I give
you a decision tree with like 100 Levels
that's not interpretable anymore right
so even within this these classes of
models uh the models that are sparser
shallow those are the ones that we can
look at read off a piece of paper try to
make some sense of them okay so that has
been one popular approach that had been
used like all the way from uh 70s 80s
and like now has more renewed interest
so the second strategy that has become
more popular in recent times is to
explain pre-built models in a post-talk
fashion right so what do I mean by that
so you could have a black box model you
could have an extremely complex deep
neural network model so we can take such
models and then pass it as inputs to our
explainer algorithms and they in turn
will break these down into simpler
models that we can understand
right so for example you can take a
whole you know let's say a 200 layer
deep neural network and then pass it
through an explanation algorithm and
that algorithm can then sort of maybe
give you important features associated
with a particular prediction right so
these sort of approaches or class of
approaches have become super popular in
recent times but have also been the
subject of a lot of discussion and
debate about their vulnerability is
advantages and so on
okay so let me just you know sort of
throw it uh back to audience and see so
which approach do you think is
preferable or is there a reason why you
would approach use some approach in one
context and not the other so out of
these two approaches building inherently
interpretable models versus explaining
pre-built models in a post-hoc fashion
which one do you prefer and why
uh that might be more applicable for
like complex models yep
information for example
and then
also the example of if you have a really
complex task and you have like a tree
algorithm if it has like a thousand
decisions that are made I wouldn't call
that very accessible so probably the
second one for more complex
yeah
so in some sense uh what you just said
can be summarized using graphs like this
right so what we need to think about is
this kind of a scenario of are there
trade-offs between interpretability and
accuracy right so for example if you are
working with some data or in a setting
where you can maybe build a five level
three and that has a very high accuracy
that's probably good enough and you know
the model is inherently interpretable
and it's also giving you accuracy and
you're done right but in a lot of real
world applications as you rightly
pointed out the data is becoming more
and more complex more and more High
dimensional and large and at which point
these kinds of trade-offs start kicking
in more and more right so in fact for
data sets in NLP vision and even some
very large tabular data sets biomedical
data sets these kinds of data what you
see is that the models that are are
often considered as inherently
interpretable like regressions or trees
they're much less accurate than models
like random Forest which is an ensemble
model or deep neural network with
several intermediate layers and so on
right so as we are running into these
situations where accuracy
interpretability trade-offs exists we
are being kind of forced to choose
post-hoc explanations otherwise we can
just rely on inherently interpretable
models right so what are these kinds of
situations so we just talked a little
bit about you know if your data is too
complex you might have to build a
complex model for the sake of accuracy
then use post-talk explanations right so
let's dig a little bit deeper or at
least give an example of when you might
be able to use inherently interpretable
models and when you might be able to use
more complex models and hence rely on
post-doc explanations right so here what
you see is like a two-dimensional data
set obviously a very simple data set a
toy example and the data is almost
linearly separable right so you can
essentially draw a line fit a hyperplane
and essentially fit a linear model and
you will be able to get a pretty good
accuracy here so in some sense here is a
setting where you can build an
inherently interpretable model and that
will also be accurate okay so now in the
other case let's say if the data has
decision boundaries which are highly
curvy and non-linear in those cases it
would be hard to build a simple model
and still have it to be accurate in
terms of its predictions right so in
that case complex models might achieve
higher accuracy and people might resort
to using post-hoc explanations if they
want to explain such models so and
Beyond this sometimes you just don't
even have enough data to build a model
from scratch so which happens a lot in
real world settings so for example if
hospitals want to sort of try and deploy
algorithms or models for scheduling
doctors with patients or like predicting
you know incoming traffic on a day a
particular Hospital might not even have
enough data collected themselves to
build such a model and they just have to
use somebody else's model to do it right
so all they get is some kind of a
proprietary black box and they may not
even really have access to it so in such
case they just have a black box and
they're stuck with post-hoc explanations
okay so in summary if you can build an
inherently interpretable model which is
also adequately accurate for your
setting so that's the way to go right so
because there is no other additional
level of complexity or approximation
there but otherwise in cases where this
is not possible post talk explanations
often come to the rescue
okay
so with that uh let's jump into the main
pieces of today's talk now that we have
hopefully set this stage for all the
initial pieces laid out the motivation
gave you high level picture of what this
field is about so today we'll be
discussing these four to five broad
topics so first we will dive into
inherently interpretable models as we
just discussed and next we'll get into
postdoc explanation methods then we'll
think about evaluations of these and you
know interesting empirical and
theoretical insights on these and close
with a discussion on the future research
directions